take a seat young lady what's happening
come on we're gonna have a talk about
the dangers of the big city see you're
gonna be invited to some parties and
some of these parties they're called
raves the people that are called Reavers
yeah and then they loved glow sticks and
and candy necklaces and hacky sacks the
music is it sounds like this okay well
be careful that that's what we want to
say
honey here's your satellite phone call
us any time and you can track our
coordinates on your manner but it's not
the same I'm an explorer like you know
honey you have the whole world to
explore go see it make friends
that's real exploring
I don't know how yes your to just be
yourself door okay
come on you're gonna miss your flight
Dora no monkeys in the city she knows
buddy
[Music]
you know the jungle it's a part of you
but exploring is not a game and you
don't look before you leave
[Music]
hello gay boots or onto something big
Dora an ancient city made of gold
what about that and your mother and I
are gonna prove it Emmie
I'm sorry sweetie you're not going look
being in the city around kids your own
age like Diego might help are you gonna
get invited some of these party called
REITs the music sounds like this got it
be careful that's what we want to say
you are way more energetic than I
remember Dora this isn't the jungle it's
high school it's life or death keep a
low profile
and just be cool door okay what is this
where did you transfer from the jungle
here's the scavenger hunt list team up
in groups of four hola Dora
you'll help us find your parents and the
lost city of gold where are we
all I see is jungle seats three
mercenaries armed oh look
boar brought a knife on the field trip
everybody who would maybe you want to
leave I will with your parents you're
all in danger
there's no need to over react she knows
this monkey
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to keep going no matter what
she's freaking awesome
I think we're safe
[Music]
[Music]